So many people beyond just me, millions of people have been inspired by your style.
And one of the fans would like to know, sirgagaOfficial...
sirgaga?
...would like to know, "With all the clothes you have, how do you decide what to wear every day..."
"...and what happens to the garments after they're worn?"
How do I decide what to wear?
It's actually not quite as complicated as some of you might imagine.
I sometimes, I mean, I'll plan months ahead for certain things.
For example, at the Grammys, the Hussein Chalayan "vessel". Although...
...it's become known as "the egg", he wants me to remind you it's "the vessel".
That took months and months of conception, and I wanted to do a whole performance art piece...
...that began on the red carpet and ended after the performance.
So, certain things take a while, and yes, I do view the vessel as a fashion piece.
But like today, I wore the same black dress...
...because I wanted the fans to recognize me a certain way when I enter the Google building.
And also on the topic of style, you have tattoos,...
...and one of the fans noticed that they're all on your left side.
So, TaylorMonster15 would like to know why all of your tattoos are on the left side of your body.
It was actually per my father's request.
So, tell us more.
He asked that I remain, on one side, slightly normal.
So I only have my tattoos on my left side. I'm also a lefty.
It's funny; my father, when I was a kid, he used to try to change my hands when I was little.
And the doctor would be like, "She was born that way, you can't."
So, I think maybe some of it, just from a neurological standpoint, might be because...
...I'm creatively driven by my left side. Maybe that's why.
But he's asked that I don't get any more on the right side, for whatever reason.
I think he sees this as my like, Marilyn Monroe side and this is my Iggy Pop side.